tha
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne à la lecture des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi qui transpose
plusieurs directives européennes dont le
paquet télécoms à sénateurs et députés
se sont mis d'accord en cmp ils ont
refusé la nomination d'un représentant
de l'état dans la recette c'est le
gendarme français des télécoms c'était
une nomination voulue par le
gouvernement malgré les critiques de
bruxelles tout de suite donc direction
l'hémicycle très bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restant en
discussion du projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions d'adaptation de la
législation au droit de l'union
européenne en matière de santé de
travail et de communications
électroniques dans la discussion
générale la parole est à madame colette
giudicelli rapporteur pour le sénat de
la commission mixte paritaire
madame la présidente madame la ministre
est cher collègue la commission mixte
paritaire qui s'est réuni au sénat le 16
février dernier est parvenu un texte
commun sur les dispositions comme disait
madame la présidente
c'est un nom assez long récents en
discussion du projet de loi portant
diverses dispositions d'adaptation au
droit de l'union européenne en matière
de santé de travail et de communications
électroniques
ce projet de loi je vous le rappelle a
pour objectif principal d'achever la
transposition en droit français des
plusieurs directives européennes ne
citerons bien sûr notamment la
directrice la directive services dont la
transposition aurait dû être achevée dès
le mois de décembre 2009 et le 3e paquet
d les télécoms c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle dont les amas au sénat a été
confiée au fonds à la commission de
l'économie
d'ailleurs chacun s'unit à eux ici la
qualité du travail qui a été accompli
par son rapporteur pour avis et bruno
retailleau auxquelles j'associe bien sûr
catherine morin desailly pour la
commission de la culture
en dépit du caractère technique de
nombreuses mesures contenues dans ce
projet de voir des discussions que nous
avons eues en commission puis en séance
publique ont été singulièrement animé je
m'y attendais pas de dire la mise en
oeuvre de la guérite services en
particulier à susciter de réelles
interrogations sans rouvrir le débat sur
le fond je pense qu'il serait utile de
procéder dans quelques années un bilan
précis des conséquences de l'ouverture
des marchés des services en europe afin
d'apprécier ses effets sur l'emploi sur
les droits des salariés ou sur la
protection des consommateurs et de
pouvoir procéder ainsi le cas échéant
aux corrections nécessaires au cours de
la navette parlementaire le projet de
loi a été substantiellement enrichi sur
proposition du gouvernement l'assemblée
nationale a notamment adopté
article d'habilitation qui autorise la
transposition par ordonnance de la
directive de 2009 sur le comité
d'entreprise européen et la mise en
cohérence de notre droit avec un
règlement relatifs aux produits
cosmétiques
elle avait défait a par ailleurs adopté
un article relatif aux médicaments de
thérapie innovante qu'elle soit
génétique ou nez qui coule un pull
autres et accepter la création d'un
commissaire du gouvernement auprès de
l'arcep l'autorité de régulation des
communications électroniques et des
postes
le sénat a lui aussi complété le texte
en y introduisant plusieurs articles
additionnels sur proposition de sa
commission de l'économie
là par exemple consacré le principe de
neutralité des réseaux est il à
autoriser les opérateurs à communiquer à
des tiers des informations sur les
réseaux de télécommunications afin de
favoriser un meilleur aménagement du
territoire
sur proposition de sa commission de la
culture
il a souhaité que tous les élèves soient
formés à un usage responsable d'internet
en revanche s'il n'avait pas suivi
l'assemblée nationale sur deux mesures
nouvelles
nous avions réduit la portée de
l'article relatif aux médicaments de
thérapie innovante cellulaire ou
génétiques afin d'éviter tous risques en
matière de sécurité sanitaire puis
supprimée l'instauration d'un
commissaire du gouvernement auprès de
l'arcep
considérant qu'elle risquait de nuire à
l'indépendance et à l'impartialité de
cette autorité administrative
le texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire est proche de celui adopté par
notre assemblée
en effet sur les treize articles qui
restaient en discussion
celles qui ont été adoptées dans la
rédaction issue des travaux du sénat et
trois autres ont fait l'objet de
modifications purement rédactionnelles
cette cmp a également confirmé notre
souhait de ne pas créer un commissaire
du gouvernement auprès de l'arcep et
c'était important pour me bruno
retailleau
la cmp est néanmoins supprimer deux
articles qui avaient été introduits au
sénat le premier que nous avions adopté
contre l'avis de la commission et du
gouvernement
pourrais-tu pour effet de modifier de
façon radicale la manière dont est
apprécié la couverture des communes par
les réseaux de téléphonie mobile et
cette mesure nous a semblé juridiquement
difficile à mettre en oeuvre et peu
opportune compte tenu de la rapidité des
évolutions technology que l'on peut
observer dans le secteur le seconde a
été supprimée parce que ces dispositions
étaient simplement redondante avec celle
d'un autre actif les lutèce au total je
considère que le texte élaboré par la
commission mixte paritaire constitue un
bon compromis vraiment dans la mesure où
il préserve les améliorations apportées
par notre assemblée et je vous invite
donc à l'approuver
ce qui permettra à la france de se
mettre rapidement en conformité avec ses
obligations européennes
il renforcera la sécurité juridique pour
les prestataires de services et les
opérateurs de télécommunications qui
travaillent dans notre pays
voilà j'ai remercié tout à l'heure
monsieur retailleau avant même qu'il
arrive et madame catherine morin
desailly je ré remercier tout
particulièrement la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales merci
madame le rapporteur la parole est à
madame nora berra secrétaire d'état
chargée de la santé
si madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je tiens tout d'abord à remercier madame
la rapporteure colette judiciary pour la
qualité du travail réalisé sur ce projet
de loi portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation de la législation au droit
de l'union européenne en matière de
santé de travail et de communications
électroniques
ce projet de loi dans le titre est
suffisamment explicite souligne bien la
variété des sujets abordés
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
comme vous le savez je n'ai pas été la
seule à le rapporter ce texte d'autres
ministres d'un sur xavier bertrand
roselyne bachelot frédéric mitterrand ou
eric besson ont porté leur disposition
du projet de loi qui relevait de leur
compétence mais cette variété ne doit
pas masquer notre objectif commun il est
de notre devoir de mettre notre droit
national en conformité avec les
obligations résultant du droit de
l'union européenne
nous devons combler les retards de notre
pays en matière de 10 transposition de
plusieurs réactive
c'était bien l'objectif de ce projet de
loi nous permettre d'achever la
transposition de plusieurs directives
d'importance majeure en particulier la
directive services est la directive
qualification vous avez exprimé dans
cette assemblée mais également à
l'assemblée nationale à plusieurs
reprises les difficultés engendrées par
l'examen de ce texte aux facettes
multiples dans un délai 6 contre 1 nous
en sommes conscients
la tâche était ardue mais vous avez sur
mesure et sont en jeu et son importance
et je vous en remercie pour la directive
services par exemple qui je le répète
n'insiste n'incite à en aucun cas moins
disant social
une grande partie des dispositions ont
déjà été transposée dans le cadre de
plusieurs textes de lois comme la loi du
4 août 2008 de modernisation de
l'économie ou encore la loi du 22
juillet 2009 de développement et de
modernisation des services touristiques
mais d'autres n'ont pas encore n'ont pas
encore pu faire l'objet d'une adoption
législative
yves définitive or nous avons depuis
longtemps dépassé la date butoir qui est
je le rappelle le 28 décembre 2009
à défaut d'une transposition complète de
la directive services nous risquons une
condamnation en manquement avec une
amende de plusieurs millions d'euros
ce projet de loi est donc nécessaire il
est même indispensable
je vais revenir rapidement sur quelques
éléments de contenu de ce texte pour
transposer la directive services
l'article premier modifie la
réglementation des débits de boissons il
prévoit une déclaration administrative
unique qui encadrera de manière
harmonisée l'ensemble des lieux de vente
de boissons alcooliques dans le souci de
garantir la sécurité la santé pardon et
l'ordre public
comme je les ai exprimé à plusieurs
reprises cette déclaration non je mange
entrera aucun coût supplémentaire pour
les mairies les articles 2 et 2 bis qui
simplifie la réglementation sur la
revente les dispositifs médicaux
d'occasion et dispositifs in vitro en
s'assurant cependant que chacun de ces
dispositifs a fait l'objet d'un
certificat de conformité dans le souci
premier de la sécurité sanitaire
l'article 8 par exemple relatifs aux
agences de mannequins introduit un
régime déclaratif pour les agences
intervenant dans le cadre de l de la
libre prestation de services
il supprime également les
incompatibilités professionnelles pour
les salariés dirigeants et associés des
agences car ces incompatibilités et son
contraire à la directive services il
leur impose cependant de prendre toutes
mesures nécessaires pour garantir la
défense des intérêts des mannequins
quels emplois et éviter des situations
de conflit d'intérêts comme vous le
voyez ces transpositions ne se fait pas
d'une manière aveugle nous veillons à
préserver nos intérêts et les garanties
qui peuvent légitimement être exigée
pour les professions concernées
ce texte nous permet aussi
de compléter notre adaptation à d'autres
dispositions du droit européen
là aussi pour éviter d'être une nouvelle
fois exposer à des condamnations
financières
ainsi l'article 5 complète la
transposition de la directive du 31 mars
2004 relative aux médicaments
traditionnels à base de plantes en nous
permettant de tenir les délais prévus ne
s'agit pas et j'insiste là dessus de
permettre la mise sur le marché de
nouveaux médicaments de ce type sans
autorisation l'article 5 bis adapte le
droit national au règlement du 13
novembre 2007 relatif aux médicaments de
thérapie innovante cet article a fait
l'objet de longues discussions ces
échanges fructueux ont ainsi permis de
garantir à la fois sécurité sanitaire et
réponse aux besoins des malades en effet
d'une part les établissements de santé
ne pourront devenir les établissements
pharmaceutiques leur vocation n'étant
pas de pros mercia lisez à grande
échelle des médicaments et d'autre part
pour les médicaments de thérapies
innovantes fabriquées à façon le niveau
de sécurité sanitaire exigé sera
identique à celui requis pour les
médicaments soumis à autorisation de
mise sur le marché communautaire
l'article 5 ter complète la
transposition de la directive du 15
février 2006 concernant la gestion de la
qualité des eaux de baignade
l'article 5 1 pièce habilite le
gouvernement à mettre en cohérence les
dispositions nationales avec celles
prévues par le règlement du 30 novembre
2009 relatif aux produits cosmétiques
l'article 14 habilite le gouvernement à
transposer la directive du 6 mai 2009
relative au comité d'entreprise européen
directive qui doit être transposée avant
juin prochain
s'agissant de cette directive relatif au
comité d'entreprise européen
nous travaillerons
bien sûr en concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux enfin l'adoption du
chapitre iii du projet de loi relatif
aux communications électroniques va nous
permettre de transposer le nouveau cadre
réglementaire européen dit paquet
télécom je me félicite du vote conforme
dont a fait l'objet
l'article 12 de loi d'habilitation du
gouvernement les travaux de la
commission mixte paritaire ont conduit à
l'adoption d'un nouvel article l 45 qui
encadre la gestion des noms de domaine
en point fr ce nouvel article répond aux
préoccupations que le conseil
constitutionnel avait exprimé en octobre
dernier
ces travaux ont inscrit dans les
objectifs généraux de régulation un
principe de non discrimination dans
l'acheminement du trafic sur les réseaux
cet objectif pourrait être complété à la
suite des prochaines conclusions des
travaux sur la neige en cours au plan
national et européen
le gouvernement feint a pris acte du
rejet de l'amendement qu'il avait
déposée proposant la création d'un
commissaire du gouvernement auprès de
l'arcep
il reste convaincu du bien fondé
car avec cet amendement le gouvernement
ne faisait qu'appliquer une proposition
du parlement et une recommandation
d'ailleurs du conseil d'état tout en
restant respectueux du droit européen
la présence d'un commissaire du
gouvernement était un gage de
transparence et aurait permis un
dialogue renforcé rendue indispensable
par les pouvoirs réglementaires de plus
en plus imbriquées que la loi confère au
gouvernement et à l'arcep
je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises ces
transpositions sont urgentes et vous en
avez bien mesurer l'importance
je crois que l'on peut se satisfaire de
l'equilibre du présent projet de loi tel
qu'issu de la cmp et je tiens à vous
remercier pour la qualité des débats et
du travail parlementaire
le parlement apporte ainsi une réponse
efficace en nous permettant de tenir les
engagements sur le plan du droit
communautaire dans le respect de notre
modèle social
merci merci madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur jean louis
masson non inscrit
la présidente madame le ministre chers
collègues
7 ce projet de loi ferait eux concerne
l'adaptation la mise en conformité du
droit du droit français avec les
directives européennes et donc je suis
très surpris qu'on ait mis dans ce texte
un article qui n'a strictement rien à
voir
un véritable cavalier législatif en
l'espèce
l'article 2 bis à concernant la gestion
d'état civil par les communes par les
communes où se trouve un appui dans les
petites communes où se trouve un hôpital
alors il y a là un vrai problème et je
tiens je tiens protester contre cette
cette dimension parce que il y a un vrai
problème et il est effectif
s'il ya une difficulté énorme dont je
vais parler sur le sujet mais comme on a
géré ça par dessus la jambe à la va vite
finalement on a on propose une solution
qui est complètement inadapté qui ne
règle rien et qui va même posé des
difficultés supplémentaires parce que
ensuite on voudra faire progresser les
choses
on nous dira oui finalement l'affairé
réglée alors quel est le problème
et bien c'est très simple vous allez
actuellement tout un tas d'hôpitaux qui
se décentralise dans des petites
communes qui ne sont plus dans les
grandes villes est pour le budget de ces
communes c'est une véritable catastrophe
je connais des communes ou de 200
habitants on se trouve un hôpital il va
falloir 8 à 10 personnes pour gérer
l'état civil car l'état civil c'est pas
seulement les actes de décès les ags
naissance s'est ensuite tout au long de
la vie de la personne des actes pour des
cartes d'identité des actes pour fille
pour ça des mariages et cetera or
demandé à une petite commune de
débourser pour gérer un état civil dix
fois son budget de fonctionnement c'est
de la folie mais est donc alors à cela
s'ajoute à tas de choses parce que quand
vous récupérez un hôpital quand vous
avez 200 habitants que vous récupérez un
hôpital vous avez tous les gens qui
meurent à l'hôpital et qui sont sans
famille dont vous devez gérer
les obsèques etc ça vous oblige a
multiplié par trois ou par 4 la taille
de votre cimetière dont il ya tout un
tas de problèmes qui se posent et j'en
passe et des meilleurs or on a géré par
ce pas cet article on essaye de donner
l'impression une fois de plus haut
niveau du gouvernement pour un
amendement parlementaire mais il a été
proposé il a été rédigé je le sais par
les services du gouvernement et je pense
que les collègues qui l'ont proposé cet
amendement aurait peut-être mieux fait
de le lire auparavant on propose un
système si règles strictement rien un
ver est strictement ya pourquoi
et bien parce que tout simplement on
nous dit les communes qui ont plus de
10% de leurs affiliés qui appuient 10%
dans l'état civil dans les communes
voisines qui vend le plus de disques
fonctions sont obligés de participer aux
frais de l'état civil
bon ça règle rien parce que ça aurait pu
régler au 19e siècle
quand vous aviez une ville centre et
plein de petits villages autour or
actuellement on sait très bien que nous
avons des conurbations et que dans une
conurbation de 30 communes qui vont
chacune 15 mille habitants et bien il y
en a aucune qui fait 10 % mais au total
15 soit une petite semaine qui se
trouvent 2 200 habitants qui se trouve à
10 kilomètres de là qu'est ce qu'il
récupère l'hôpital et bien cette commune
elle est vraiment dans une situation
inextricable donc on va rien régler du
tout dans de nombreux cas on va rien
rien du tout en donnant l'impression
qu'on règle les problèmes et ça je pense
que c'est véritablement une très
mauvaise chose ce qu'il fallait faire
c'était que la dotation globale de
fonctionnement des communes et bien soit
majorée à due concurrence des coûts de
l'état civil ce qui se fait dans un
certain nombre d'autres domaines
et là on aurait vraiment régler la
situation au contraire dans le cas
d'espèce je le dis bien c'est vraiment
un coup d'épée dans l'eau ou un certain
nombre de personnes ont voulu donner
l'impression à des mères à des
municipalités qui gère l affaire est
sans suite le dossier
eh bien on a laissé en acier le
gouvernement comme d'habitude proposer
quelque chose qui règle rien et bien moi
je le dis c'est infligions et ce encore
plus affligeant
parce que on nous colle ça
dans une affaire concernant les
directives européennes moi je le dis
très clairement
qu'est ce que la gestion d'état civil
par les communes par une petite commune
vi récupère un hôpital à avoir avec les
directives européennes
madame le ministre bien vous me
répondiez parce que c'est vraiment de
l'aberration complètent bien
la parole est à monsieur gilbert barbier
pour le rds eux
madame la présidente même une issue
chers collègues
n'ayant pu être présent lors de l'examen
de ce texte en première lecture
alors même que j'avais déposé des
amendements je souhaitais exprimer ici
quelques remarques de forme et de fond à
ce stade ultime des conclusions de la
commission 10 paritaire première
concerne les conditions dans lesquelles
nous avons travaillé en effet ce projet
de loi donnait lieu à un large et riche
débat en commission des affaires
sociales qui s'était conclue par une
position favorable à la suppression de
nombreux articles
or le débat dans l'hémicycle qui s'est
dégourdi su se dérouler le 10 février
dernier est loin de traduire l'esprit
est la volonté de notre commission le
rapporteur a bien donné un avis
favorable aux amendements de suppression
en précisant qu'il était contre à titre
personnel quant aux membres de la
commission
compte tenu des dates à laquelle se
discuter ce projet beaucoup étaient
absents
certes je peux comprendre qu'il soit
difficile pour tous les groupes de
siéger en nombre en séance jeudi soir à
trois heures du matin
moi-même je n'ai pu être là ce sont mes
collègues denis detcheverry daniel
marsin qui ont porté mes amendements
quoi qu'il en soit il est tout à fait
anormal d'étudier un texte aussi
important à cette heure aussi tardive et
on aurait pu espérer un résultat
conforme à la décision de la coalition
même si l'on peut comprendre des
positions personnelles
souhaitant que cette situation ne se
reproduise plus d'une manière générale
l'organisation du travail il n'est pas
très correct on nous laisse trop peu de
temps pour examiner des textes touchant
des domaines aussi livre aussi
différents que ceux qui sont contenus
dans ce projet de loi il y avait certes
le rapporteur elle est imposée par
l'union européenne mais là encore la
précipitation nous empêche d'imaginer
d'autres dispositifs de transposition
peut-être plus satisfaisants que ceux
proposés car sur le fond le groupe rdse
a des réserves comme l'a relevé le
rapporteur lui-même certains articles du
projet peuvent susciter des craintes
parfois légitimes
c'est le cas notamment de ce qui vient
d'être évoquée concernant l'article 2 2
bis et trois sur lequel des amendements
de suppression avait été proposée
concernant les produits de santé s'agit
de permettre à des organismes établis
dans un autre état membre de venir
exercer en france pour la certification
des dispositifs médicaux et l'évaluation
des établissements de services sociaux
et médico sociaux qui sont aujourd'hui
exclusivement le fait d'organiser
habilité par l'afssaps ou la même si
loin de nous l'idée de jeter l'opprobre
sur quelconque organisme ou de s'opposer
par principe à la libre prestation de
services mais s'agissant du domaine
social et médical nous sommes soucieux
de garder un haut niveau de qualité et
de sécurité
comment s'assurer que les organismes
établis dans un autre état membre
répondent aux mêmes exigences
d'intégrité d'objectivité et de
compétences que les organismes établis
en france seront ils soumis aux mêmes
contrôles aux mêmes sanctions
chacun sait bien que la formation les
pratiques ne sont pas les mêmes d'un
pays à l'autre
par ailleurs le texte supprime
l'exigence d'une attestation technique
pour la revente de dispositifs médicaux
d'occasion laissant le soin aux
revendeurs de justifier de l'entretien
régulier du maintien des performances de
ceux ci une attestation par un organisme
agréé par l'afssaps d'une garantie utile
en cas d'éventuels contentieux entre
l'acquéreur et le vendeur et dans
l'hypothèse de ce dernier dépose son
bilan
une fois la transaction effectuée ils
sont en effet difficile de mettre en
cause sa responsabilité
le nouveau président de la chaise sodis
youn et lors de la commission sur le
médiateur nous a dit ignorer une telle
transposition alors qu'il existe à mon
sens dans cet organisme à la haute
autorité de santé
une commission d'évaluation des
dispositifs médicaux et des technologies
de santé présidée par l'éminent
professeur
michel dubernard ancien député on peut
même quand même s'étonner que l'achat
est ce ne soit pas saisie de ce 32 ce
problème de transplantation directive là
encore convient de privilégier la
sécurité s'agissant de la santé publique
et des dispositifs qui retrouve une très
grande variété de produits laissera les
lits médicalisés les stimulateurs
cardiaques
les scanners elles sont destinées à des
milliers de personnes comment
pouvez-vous nous répondre sur ces points
madame le ministre
enfin je ne cache ne cache pas que je
suis réservé sur le recours aux
ordonnances pour transposer les
directives l'urgence et la technicité
des dispositions ne saurait suffire à
justifier cette méthode notamment pour
les produits cosmétiques dont les
nombreux composants peuvent s'avérer
potentiellement dangereux pour la santé
chargé par l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
techniques d'un rapport sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens
vous le savez madame le ministre que ces
problèmes produits cosmétiques sont à
surveiller de très près quant au
troisième paquet télécom il convient il
contient des dispositions sur des sujets
qui méritent une vraie discussion que ne
permet pas le recours à une ordonnance
je pense en particulier au principe de
neutralité des réseaux à la couverture
du territoire au droit à la vie privée
de chacun sur plusieurs de ces points
le sénat a effectué un travail important
en témoigne pour ne citer qu'elles la
proposition de loi relative aux
télécommunications adopté en décembre
dernier à l'initiative de mon collègue
daniel marsin du groupe rdse
il est vrai que le 3e paquet télécom
comprend des dispositions très technique
exigeant certes une transposition
maximale qui laisse peu de marge de
manoeuvre
vous nous avez aussi transmis le projet
d'ordonnancé
il n'en demeure pas moins que pour le
parlement
cela signifie se défaire de ses
prérogatives législatives ce qui est
loin d'être satisfaisant en réalité
cette atteinte au pouvoir du parlement
est la conséquence directe du retard
chronique de la france dans la
transposition du droit communautaire
nous avons déjà eu par le passé a adopté
à la hâte des lois d'habilitation pour
transposer des textes à caractère
législatif
il est pour le moins curieux que notre
pays qui se targue souvent d'être l'un
des moteurs de l'approfondissement de
l'union des temps ce domaine un bien
mauvais élève se situant au 15e rang des
états membres dysfonctionnements des
administrations manque de volonté
politique ou encombrement de l'ordre du
jour des assemblées chacun explique à sa
manière les causes de ces piètres
performances
quoi qu'il en soit je crois à madame le
ministre qu'il conviendrait de formuler
quelques propositions pour remédier
d'une manière durable
je ne voulais pas terminer sans exprimer
un motif de satisfaction
nous approuvons en effet l'initiative
consistant à charger l'arcep d'éclairer
le parlement sur les enjeux de la
qualité de service de l'accès à internet
est de l'interconnexion entre collègues
retailleau via proposé que le principe
de neutralité s'impose à l'arcep
enfin dans sa grande sagesse la
commission mixte paritaire a confirmé la
suppression du commissaire du
gouvernement auprès de cet organisme
il était important pour beaucoup sur ces
bancs de garantir son indépendance et
son impartialité
quoi qu'il en soit c'est même avec
satisfaite satisfaction le groupe rdse
s'abstiendra sur ce texte
merci la parole est au président guy
fischer pour le groupe crc spg
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la rapporteure même la présidente
de la commission mes chers collègues
cela ne vous étonnera pas après le
processus qui a conduit à ce que notre
haute assemblée et l'assemblée nationale
est adopté pour l'essentiel le projet de
loi déposé par le gouvernement et que
nos deux chambres se soient entendus en
commission mixte paritaire sur
l'élaboration d'un texte
comment celui qui est mise au vote
aujourd'hui que les sénatrices et
sénateurs du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et des sénateurs du
parti de gauche maintiennent leur
opposition à ce projet de loi une
opposition sur la forme et sur le fond
en effet une nouvelle fois le
gouvernement a fait le choix de
transposer dans l'urgence des éléments
de directives européennes demandant aux
parlementaires d'accepter de travailler
sous la pression de se dessaisir d'une
partie de leurs compétences en
autorisant le gouvernement à recourir
aux ordonnances telle que prévue par
l'article 38 de notre constitution est
ce au motif que ce même gouvernement
n'aurait pas transposer ces directives
dans des délais raisonnables
cela n'est pas sérieux et fait encourir
à notre pays d'importantes sanctions
financières le gouvernement pour nous
contraindre ou plutôt pour contrainte sa
majorité joue d'ailleurs sur cette
question sensible dans le contexte
financier tendu qui est le nôtre
alors je le dis tranquillement mais avec
fermeté cette méthode de gouvernance
madame la ministre dans laquelle les
parlementaires ont à pâtir du manque de
sérieux des ministres compétents doit
cesser il faut absolument que l'on
puisse
travailler sur le fond sur des sujets
très importants et qui vont engager
l'avenir de nos concitoyens une grande
démocratie comme la nôtre ne peut
fonctionner durablement ainsi c'est à
croire que les ministres prennent
volontairement du routard pour vérité
pour éviter qu'un véritable débat ne
s'installe tantôt parlement que dans
notre société dans son ensemble car nous
n'oublions pas qu'il s'agit là de
transposer pour une bonne part des
éléments de la directive services plus
connu sous le nom de directive
bolkenstein est du paquet télécom dont
chacun sait qu'ils participent à
l'accroissement de la concurrence libre
et non faussée dans un secteur jadis
protéger c'est d'ailleurs la finalité
d'une bonne partie de ce projet de loi
très divers dans son contenu puisque en
réalité votre gouvernement a opté afin
d'éviter une convergence des
mécontentements et des oppositions pour
une transposition sectorielle plutôt que
transversale c'est à dire une
transposition métier par métier plutôt
qu'une transposition globale comme cela
a eu lieu dans d'autres pays de l'union
européenne nous sommes pour notre part
pas dupe et nous savons bien que votre
projet européen se limite à adapter les
législations nationales à la loi du
marché à faire primer l'économie et ses
caprices sur les besoins humains et
sociaux
c'est d'ailleurs ce constat qui nous
avait conduits à nous opposer en son
temps à la directive services et a
refusé comme la majorité des français
le projet de constitution européenne que
vous avez imposées et qui consacrait
cette prédominance de l'économie je note
d'ailleurs avec satisfaction que nous
sommes de plus en plus nombreux à le
penser
y compris dans cet hémicycle bien que au
fil du temps et sous la pression
gouvernementale et bien les oppositions
se soient effacés
et y compris donc sur les mares les
bancs de la majorité sénatoriale
mais comme l'a rappelé notre collègue
barbier en commission des affaires
sociales beaucoup à l'ump se sont
vivement opposés à certaines
dispositions contenues dans ce projet de
loi je pense par exemple à celle
concernant la revente d'occasion du
matériel médical ou celles concernant
les assistants de service social
une opposition qui s'est traduit par une
situation inédite me semble-t-il aucun
des sénateurs ump membres de la
commission des affaires sociales
la commission saisie au fond n'est
intervenu pour défendre ce projet de loi
c'est dire et on les comprend car ce
projet de loi malgré son apparente
diversité son côté fourre-tout n'est pas
anodin ainsi l'article 2 prévoit tout
simplement de déréguler la revente de
matériel médical d'occasion dans la
mesure où la certification de sa
conformité qui est indispensable en cas
de revente ne sera plus exclusivement
établie par un organisme habilité par
l'afssaps mais pourra être confié à un
autre organisme désigné par les
autorités compétentes d'un autre état
membre de l'union européenne
cela risque d'entraîner une dégradation
importante des missions de contrôle
quand on sait que selon les pays bien
les normes ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
et ce d'autant plus que dans le même
temps
l'article de supprimer l'exigence d'une
attestation technique pour la revente
des dispositifs médicaux d'occasion
laissant le soin aux revendeurs de
justifier de l'entretien régulier et du
maintien des performances de ceux ci en
somme vous remplacer un document
administratif d'une certaine valeur
puisque reposant sur l'expertisé d'une
agence nationale par une simple
déclaration de bonne foi du revendeur
convenait que ce n'est pas sérieux
dès lors qu'il s'agit de secteurs qui
engage la responsabilité des patients et
la sécurité des utilisateurs
quant à l'article 3 vivement contesté en
commission par notre collègue sylvie
desmarescaux rapporteur pour le secteur
médico social du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
il prévoit d'autoriser des prestataires
européens à exercer de manière
temporaire et occasionnelle en france
les missions d'évaluation et de contrôle
des établissements d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes les ehpad
des instituts médico éducatifs les
éléments qui doivent comme vous le savez
procédé tous les sept ans à des
évaluations externes et pour ce faire
cet article propose de dispenser ces
établissements de la ville de
l'habilitation délivré par la naine
outre que cette disposition nous
inquiète quant à la qualité du service
rendu par ces opérateurs européens et à
ses conséquences sur les personnels sur
les personnes accueillies dans ces
établissements qui sont par nature
particulièrement fragile nous redoutons
que cet article ait pour effet
d'affaiblir les établissements nationaux
en effet si les opérateurs européens
sont dispensés de la libye de
l'habilitation délivré par là même qui
est gage de qualité de sécurité et
disons le de sérieux et bien les
opérateurs français eux ils demeurent
soumis cette situation discriminatoire à
l'égard des opérateurs nationaux
pourraient avoir pour conséquence leur
disparition progressive
ce sont après tout les conséquences
logiques à chaque doping sociale à ceci
près que cela risque de ne pas être sans
conséquence sur l'axé curité et la
qualité de vie des personnes
vieillissantes ou en situation de
handicap vous proposait d'appliquer la
même logique celle de la concurrence
déloyale entre les opérateurs nationaux
et européens à un domaine très
particulier du monde de la culture
le spectacle vivant l'article 6 propose
en effet de permettre aux
opérateurs privés de se dispenser de
l'obligation faite aux opérateurs
français de posséder une licence alors
que cette licence prévoit que
l'opérateur de spectacle doit détenir la
capacité juridique qui l'autorisent à
exercer une activité commerciale et doit
également avoir suivi une formation de
500 heures très importante en matière de
sécurité ce qui n'est pas anodin
dès lors qu'il s'agit d'accueillir du
public
par ailleurs vous remettez en cause bien
plus qu'un simple mécanisme
d'autorisation toute une conception du
dialogue social lequel n'est
naturellement pas étranger à la qualité
du spectacle vivant dans notre pays dans
la mesure où cette licence parce qu'elle
est elle assure le respect du principe
de présomption de salariat permet de
lutter contre le travail illégal
l'article 8 que nous avions proposé de
supprimer ce à quoi le gouvernement et
la majorité sénatoriale s'était opposée
prévoit pourtant de supprimer les
incompatibilités pour l'obtention de la
licence d' agence de mannequins dont
l'objet est d'éviter des conflits
d'intérêts qui pourraient se produire au
détriment des mannequins ces derniers
qui peuvent être très jeunes parfois
même mineurs peuvent être
particulièrement fragile et il nous
semble impensable d'amoindrir des règles
censées les protéger en confiant aux
agents le soin de veiller à ce que les
intérêts des mannequins soient protégés
alors même que ce ne sont que ce sont
les agents qui ont tout à gagner en cas
de conflit d'intérêts enfin pour
conclure comment ne pas souligner le
risque fait peser
l'article 10 de ce projet de loi sur le
secteur social en effet celui ci vise à
restreindre de manière importante les
conditions d'exercice de la profession
d'assistant de service social
le demandeur ressortissant d'un état
membre serait dispensé de justifiez de 2
années d'expérience en tant qu assistant
de service social
s'il a obtenu un titre dans son pays
même si la profession n'y ait pas
réglementée or en france
la profession est depuis longtemps
réglementée et si elle l'est c'est que
les pouvoirs publics ont cru à raison
qu'il était impératif que les
professionnels qui accompagnent des
personnes en difficultés sociales et
financières disposent d'une formation
adéquate et tous les présidents de
conseils généraux ils sont nombreux dans
cette assemblée comme les conseillers
généraux et bien sont au coeur et
connaissent bien ces problématiques
il faut dire que les assistants de
service social interviennent auprès de
publics déjà très fragilisé pour qui ces
professionnels sont souvent l'ultime
rampe à mes chers collègues nous
n'aurions pas eu à débattre de cet
article
si le gouvernement avait décidé comme
l'y autorise le droit européen
d'invoquer les raisons impérieuses
d'intérêt général or il s'y est refusé
au mépris des conséquences des
politiques européennes sur les
populations
dès lors qu'il s'agit de lever tous les
obstacles existants et freinant la libre
concurrence
ce cette logique qui nous a conduits à
nous opposer à ce projet de loi et à la
directive services
nous considérons en effet qu'il est
capital que les pouvoirs publics et pour
principal pour seul objectif de garantir
la qualité et la sécurité des services
proposés particulièrement lorsqu'ils
s'adressent à des publics fragilisés ou
vise à répondre à des besoins essentiels
tels que la santé le secteur social ou
le secteur culturel une politique à
milieu de ce qui nous est proposé ici
raison pour laquelle comme je vous
l'annonçais en préalable
nous voterons contre ce projet de loi
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole est à madame 1
catherine morin desailly pour l'union
centriste
madame la présidente madame la milice
mes chers collègues c'est dans l'urgence
une fois encore que notre parlement
examine et la transposition de
différentes directives importante
je pense notamment la directive dite
services dont le projet rappelons le
avait cristallisé le débat relatif au
projet de traité constitutionnel
européen en 2005
aujourd'hui il ya urgence car la
directive du 12 décembre 2006 relative
aux services dans le marché intérieur et
dont le présent texte achève la
transposition aurait dû être totalement
intégré à notre droit en décembre 2009
encore plus impressionnant est le cas de
la directive du 7 décembre 2005 relative
à la reconnaissance des qualifications
professionnelles que transpose aussi ce
projet de loi dont le délai de mise en
oeuvre a expiré en octobre 2007 plus de
trois ans de retard madame la ministre
ce n'est pas rien alors que notre pays
membre fondateur de l'union devrait être
un exemple en la matière de
transposition
je tiens à rappeler que la france est le
sixième pays le plus en retard en la
matière sur 27
par ce comportement la france portent
évidemment atteinte au principe de
sécurité juridique qui nécessite de la
prévisibilité et de la stabilité
la transposition des directives
communautaires et bien sûr de notre
réglementation générale
j'ajoute enfin qu'en termes financiers
cette négligence du gouvernement a coûté
cher en 2005 et en 2008 nous avons été
condamnés à une astreinte semestriel de
57,8 millions d'euros et à une amende
forfaitaire de 10 millions d'euros avec
un déficit proche de 8% du pib
nous ne pouvons tous amant tout
simplement plus nous permettre ce genre
de fantaisie pour revenir au texte
proprement dit un ensemble quelque peu
été au clic nous en avons tous convenu
lors des débats je tenais à réaffirmer
la position de notre groupe qui était
globalement favorable aux dispositions
adoptées par le sénat
bien entendu un titre personnel et en
tant que rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et la communication
accueil particulièrement bien les
dispositions de la directive services
qui permettent notamment aux architectes
de l'union d'exercer leur profession en
france en tant qu'associé d'une société
d'architecturé et se soutient également
les dispositions qui ont été prises pour
les professeurs de danse facilitant
ainsi leur insertion professionnelle au
sein de l'union
je m'attardais quelques instants sur le
paquet télécom que le projet de loi
entend attend transposée par voie
d'ordonnancé
sur ce point je me réjouis que des
objectifs culturels la promotion de la
diversité culturelle ou linguistique le
pluralisme des médias que ces objectifs
puissent être pris en compte par l'arcep
dans le cadre de sa compétence
d'attribution de fréquences bien sûr
nous resterons très vigilants lors de
l'examen du texte de ratification des
ordonnances la commission mixte
paritaire a eu en outre la sagesse de
maintenir la position du sénat sur des
apports que je considère fondamentaux
notamment la neutralité des réseaux
la disposition fruit des conclusions de
la table ronde que nous avons eu à coeur
d'organiser avec pierre hérisson et
bruno retailleau que ce dernier
rapporteur pour avis a introduites dans
le texte fixe désormais dans le cpc eux
le principe de la neutralité de
l'internet tout en garantissant et c'est
important un caractère législatif souple
et consensuelle qui permettra de faire
vivre le débat et d'adapter la loi en
fonction des évolutions futures
je me réjouis également que la cmp est
maintenu un autre apport essentiel des
sénateurs notamment centristes en
confirmant qu'aucun représentant de
l'état ne siégerait au sein de l'arcep
c'est une condition sinequanone de
l'indépendance qui caractérise les
autorités de régulation et madame la
ministre qui a rappelé que c'est ce qu'a
rappelé avec la plus grande fermeté la
commission européenne vous le savez mon
collègue avait mort et avec qui j'ai
avec lequel j'ai fortement défendu
l'amendement de suppression reviendra
bien sûr plus en détail sur ce point
mais je tiens à redire qui semblait plus
que problématique un commissaire
gouvernement soit président pardon soit
présent au sein de cette autorité
d'autant que l'état est actionnaire
majoritaire de l'opérateur historique
en s'attaquant et c'est un lapsus en
sata corps de la sorte à l'arcep un
doute été jetés sur la transparence de
son fonctionnement est posé toute une
série de questions sur le devenir de
toutes les autorités de régulation comme
par exemple j'avais eu à coeur de le
dire le csa qui dispose lui aussi d'une
mission d'attribution de fréquences et a
pour mission très essentiel de garantir
le pluralisme politique des médias le
matière de la suppression d'un
commissaire du gouvernement à l'arcep
s'inscrit donc pleinement dans cette
exigence d'indépendance
je conclurai par un sujet qui été
longuement débattue en cmp à savoir le
maintien de l'amendement que j'avais
porté au nom de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation et de la
communication et qui visait dans le
cadre de l'est de l'enseignement
d'éducation civique à faire bénéficier
les élèves du sensibilisation bien sûr
aux potentialités mais également aux
risques encourus sur le net est une
pratique responsable des outils
interactifs sur la toile ce dispositif
qui elle rappelé complète l'article 16
de la loi hadopi qui prévoit une large
sensibilisation des collégiens au droit
de la propriété intellectuelle aux
dangers du téléchargement illégal d'un
parc protégé et bien sûr tout cela au
cours de l'enseignement de technologie
et d'informatique et après avoir
approfondi cette question de l'éducation
médias nous pensions indispensable quand
dehors du fameux b2i des collèges et au
sein de l'enseignement d'éducation
civique les élèves soient véritablement
forme et à la maîtrise leur image
publique à l'analyse réfléchi et
critique des informations qui circulent
sur la toile et à l'utilisation
responsable des réseaux sociaux et des
applications interactives tient à
rappeler chif aujourd'hui ces 91 % des
13 24 ans qui ont un profil facebook
dès lors que la cmp a permis le maintien
des apports des sénateurs sur ce texte
je lui apporte bien sûr mon soutien et
celui du groupe de l'union centriste
et avant de conclure je tiens à
remercier notre rapporteur qui on en
conviendra n'a pas eu la tâche très
facile sur ce texte
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci madame la sénatrice la parole et à
monsieur michel teston pour le groupe
socialiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales mesdames et
messieurs les rapporteurs et rapporteur
pour avis chères et chers collègues nous
arrivons à la fin du processus d'examen
de ce projet de loi dit d'adaptation de
la législation au droit de l'union
européenne en matière de santé de
travail et de communications
électroniques
une remarque générale d'abord madame la
ministre le groupe socialiste demande
que le gouvernement cesse de légiférer
dans l'urgence et pire encore par
ordonnance sur des sujets essentiels
pour nos concitoyens
cette manière de procéder est un moyen
de transposer ses directives en court
circuitant les parlementaires et en
éludant un vrai débat en outre comme l'a
également souligné mon collègue yves
daudigny lors de la réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire
la méthode choisie par le gouvernement
le dispense de l'avis du conseil d'état
sur le fond quand fernand la
transposition de la directive services
nous avons bien saisi le choix du
gouvernement de l'intégrer au droit
national
par petites touches évitant ainsi un
texte de loi spécifique et partant un
débat sans doute plus long et plus
difficile que celui concernant les
établissements de soins les
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
look texte conduit ni plus ni moins au
démantèlement et à la dérégulation les
dispositions relatives à la santé au
travail de ce texte ne sont pas
acceptables pour notre groupe
j'en viens aux dispositions relatives
aux communications électroniques
là encore le gouvernement souhaitait
atrabile it et à transposer par
ordonnances et les directives et le
règlement appelé troisième paquet
télécom en raison de l'obligation de
respecter la date buteur de
transposition il
c'est au 25 mai 2011 cette obligation et
real
ceci étant comment ne pas rappeler votre
troisième paquet télécom a été adopté
par le parlement le conseil européen le
25 novembre 2009
or le projet de loi de transposition n'a
été déposée sur le bureau de l'assemblée
nationale que le 15 septembre 2010 il
aurait donc était possible d'engager la
transcription de ces dispositions en
droit français
selon la procédure législative normal si
le gouvernement n'avait pas autant tardé
alors plusieurs intervenants à
l'assemblée nationale ont justifié le
recours aux ordonnances par le caractère
technique du sujet effectivement les
directives et le règlement comporte des
dispositions techniques mais il n'en
demeure pas moins qu'ils concernent la
vie quotidienne
il conditionne en partie la desserte du
territoire en service à très haut débit
et la qualité des prestations de
téléphonie et d'internet
en procédant pas voir d'ordonnancé le
gouvernement a privé les parlementaires
d'un débat sur des enjeux majeurs comme
la séparation fonctionnelle la
réorganisation et la libéralisation du
spectre radioélectrique ou le service
universel ainsi la possibilité reconnu
aux autorités nationales d'imposer aux
opérateurs une séparation entre les
activités opérationnelles et serre qui
sont liés à la gestion du réseau aurait
mérité un vrai débat entre ceux qui
voient un moyen de renforcer la
concurrence et ce dont je fais partie
qui craignent qu'elle ne contribue à
augmenter le prix de l'accès au réseau
et à retarder les investissements dans
la fibre optique
le troisième paquet télécom met en place
en outre un organe européen des
régulateurs nationaux avec un risque
qu'ils se substituent aux autorités de
régulation nationales
si un texte spécifique avait été déposée
et examiné dans le cadre de la procédure
législative normal nous aurions pu
débattre de l'intérêt de mécanismes
alternatifs et je pense en particulier à
la co-régulation qui est défendu par
catherine trautmann
députée européene dans une logique de
meilleure coopération entre les
régulateurs nation tous ces thèmes
touchant un humain de plus en plus
important pour la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens aurait mérité qu'on leur
consacrer davantage de temps
la neutralité des réseaux est prévue à
l'article 11 ter il s'agit d'une
transposition a minima
défendant ce principe renforçant les
pouvoirs du régulateur
à ce sujet il est important de rappeler
qu'une mission parlementaire réfléchit
sur la question et que les dernières
rencontres parlementaires sur l'économie
numérique qui se sont tenus le 8 février
dernier était consacré à la neutralité
d'internet
le troisième paquet télécom érigée en
principe contraignant la neutralité
technologique c'est à dire la liberté
d'utiliser n'importe quelle technologie
dans une bande de fréquence et pose le
principe de la neutralité du service
c'est à dire la liberté d'utiliser le
spectre pour offrir n'importe quel
service il s'agit là encore à mon sens
de favoriser la concurrence et donc le
développement d'une nouvelle gamme de
services tels que la télévision
numérique terrestre la télévision mobile
le gouvernement français ne risque-t-il
pas de tirer argument cette réforme pour
repousser l'introduction de l'accès
internet dans le champ du service
universel quant au dividende numérique
il y aura-t-il une adaptation pour
permettre une juste répartition des
fréquences libérées entre les services
audiovisuels
le haut débit et le très haut débit dans
ce contexte incertain
notre groupe a défendu une nouvelle fois
un amendement visant à instaurer un
service universel en matière d'internet
avec la possibilité pour tous en
particulier les plus modestes d'accéder
à ce service à un coût abordable
cet amendement n'a pas cité adopté et je
le regrette
nous avions réussi aussi à faire adopter
un amendement créant un article 12 bis à
amendement déposé par hervé maurey et
qui disposait que je cite
une commune réputée couverte quand sur
l'ensemble de son territoire
chante offert au public les services
répondant aux obligations de permanence
de qualité et de disponibilité fin de
citation cet amendement
le groupe socialiste avait déposé le
même nous paraissait essentiel dans la
mesure où de nombreuses communes ne sont
pas totalement couvertes par les réseaux
mobiles en commission mixte paritaire
les rapporteurs et le rapporteur en fait
adopter un amendement de suppression de
cet article
certes le même amendement avait été
adopté précédemment
lors de la discussion de la proposition
de loi notre collègue marc st
toutefois nous savons pas quel sort sera
réservé à cette proposition de loi à
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai tendance à penser que ce sera
probablement un triste sort force est
donc de constater que nous n'avançons
pas cette question pourtant essentielle
probablement parce que les opérateurs
voient d'un très mauvais oeil une
nouvelle obligation leur incombant il
n'en demeure pas moins que la couverture
des partis habiter de chaque commune est
une nécessité en particulier si l'on
veut contribuer à la revitalisation des
territoires fragiles d'ailleurs la même
remarque peut être fait s'agissant du
haut et du très haut débit alors à
l'issue de travaux
quelle conclusion pouvons-nous tirer
d'abord que la méthode employée par le
gouvernement pour la transposition des
directives n'est pas acceptable
ensuite et sur le fond de nombreuses
dispositions auraient mérité un débat
plus approfondi
dans le cas de textes de loi dédiée
quant aux communications électroniques
est bien l'un des amendements essentiels
que nous avions fait voter la couverte
au total en téléphonie mobile a été
supprimée en commission mixte paritaire
en conséquence et compte tenu de toutes
les réserves que nous pouvons émettre
sur ce texte
le groupe socialiste se prononcera con
merci la parole est à monsieur bruno
retailleau on le groupe non inscrits
dans la présidente
la rapporteure la président de la
commission des affaires sociales chers
collègues je me contenterai simplement
aux articles qui concernent le paquet
télécom 3 pour indiquer que ce texte
bien évidemment qui se rapporte aux
communications électroniques ça n'est
pas un texte de rupture mais ça n'est
pas non plus un texte tout à fait anodin
je pense que les dispositions qui vont
être adoptés je l'espère qu'ils l'ont
été en tout cas en commission mixte
paritaire vont dans le bon sens je
voudrais simplement rappeler que c'est
un texte quand même important parce
qu'ils comptent il concerne un secteur
fondamental de notre économie
le problème aujourd'hui de la france et
la croissance molle notre problème
français c'est une productivité qui est
atone or une étude qui vient d'être
présenté ce matin à bercy révèle que
l'économie numérique le numérique en
général contribue à hauteur de 25% à la
croissance française est que depuis 15
ans l'économie numérique a contribué à
créer pratiquement un million d'emplois
directs et indirects c'est donc un texte
fondamental pour l'avenir d'un secteur
parfaitement stratégique de l'économie
française
pour ce qui concerne les apports de ce
texte je m'en tiendrais simplement main
quelques minutes qu'ils sont réservés à
a3 apport majeur
d'abord c'est un texte qui va renforcer
la régulation et il y a quelques années
ça n'était pas évident on entendait un
certain nombre d'échos et davy qui était
plutôt favorable à un retrait de la
régulière de la régulation pour pouvoir
conforter une forme d'auto régulation
des marchés la crise est passée par là
et je pense que renforcer le régulateur
cela va dans le bon sens cela va
d'autant plus dans le bon sens que
désormais le régulateur aura comme
objectif toujours bien entendu la
concurrence mais pas seulement
il devra aussi tenir compte de
l'investissement et par conséquent de
l'emploi ça c'est le premier point en ce
qui concerne la régulation et des moyens
d'indépendance qui vont conforter le
régulateur le deuxième point deuxième
apport majeur concerne des
problématiques qui sont un peu nouvelle
dans ce paquet télécom 3 il s'agit
notamment des mesures favorisant la
meilleure information des consommateurs
des mesures favorisant une meilleure
protection aussi pour les consommateurs
je pense eu à ce qu'on appelle la
publicité automatique par rapport
notamment au phénomène des cookies le
consentement des consommateurs sera
recherchée pour que des sociétés des
entreprises puissent avoir accès à ce
type de technique commerciale autre
problématique nouvelle la sécurité des
réseaux ce n'est pas l'heure où il ya
quelques jours on apprenait que bercy
avait fait l'objet d'une attaque qu'on
apprend il ya quelques heures que
l'elysée et le quai d'orsay ont eux
aussi fait l'objet de même cyberattaques
la sécurité des réseaux ne viennent pas
un sujet de plus en plus important je me
félicite d'ailleurs que le paquet
télécom pour la première fois ce
troisième paquet télécom puisse y faire
allusion et et même au delà puisqu'il ya
un certain nombre de mesures qui seront
là en même temps possible pour sécuriser
les réseaux
enfin je voudrais souligner deux apports
du parlement et notamment du sénat je
crois que nous avons un sécuriser le
régime français d'attribution des noms
de domaine qui avait été fragilisée par
une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité je pense que le
résultat est positif est enfin là encore
catherine morin dessailly en a parlé
tout à l'heure nous avons aussi
conforter le principe qui est
fondamental pour internet de la
neutralité des réseaux
il s'agissait simplement d'encourager un
internet qui soit et qui reste un bien
stratégique collective qui ne soit pas
ni privatiser ni balkaniser je ne peux
pas m'étendre sur ce principe là mais
l'idée d'un internet ouvert
il est fondamental pour l'avenir du web
en france et dans le monde et je me
félicite que avec catherine morin
dessailly 9e puis pu trouver un accord
et que le sénat la commission mixte
paritaire et ratifié voilà je voudrais
pour terminer mais aussi félicité le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et puis le rapporteur qui n'ont
pas toujours effectivement une tâche
facile je crois que le paquet télécom 3
n'est pas effectivement un texte de
rupture mais c'est un texte il va
permettre à l'économie numérique de
continuer son déploiement et son
développement merci la parole est à
monsieur hervé maurey pour l'union
centriste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
affaires sociales madame la rapporteure
les commissions mixtes paritaires ne
sont pas toujours loin s'en faut source
de grande satisfaction pour les
sénateurs puisque trop souvent les
positions exprimées par notre assemblée
de force et conviction ont disparu des
textes soumis à notre approbation après
cmp les exemples hélas ne manquent pas
même si je pense plus particulièrement à
cet instant à la récente réforme des
collectivités territoriales
le texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
nous offrent au moins une satisfaction
celle de voir le vote du sénat
confirmé sur un sujet important un sujet
qui avait fait débat ici mais aussi à
l'assemblée nationale et dans les médias
celui de la création d'un commissaire du
gouvernement auprès de l'arcep proposé
au détour d'un amendement à l'assemblée
nationale par le gouvernement
nous sommes d'autant plus satisfaits de
la disparition de l'article 13 que je
l'avais proposé à notre commission de
l'économie puis avec catherine morin
desailly et l'ensemble du groupe de
l'union centriste à notre assemblée
cette position ferme du sénat a donc été
obtenu contre l'avis de
la commission et du gouvernement grâce à
notre groupe sur lequel je le rappelle
régulièrement dans l'espoir que le
gouvernement et nos amis de l'ump
finissent par l'entendre il n'y a pas de
majorité au sénat
cette décision nous l'avons prise non
pas comme l'avait laissé entendre le
ministre sous la pression de l'arcep ou
sous la pression de la commission ou
pour le contrarier
mais parce que nous considérions que le
sénat a un rôle particulier dans nos
institutions et dans notre histoire en
matière de défense des libertés
publiques et nous venons encore selon le
même schéma de le vivre pour la
déchéance de nationalité
les centristes ont permis au sénat
d'affirmer son attachement une liberté
fondamentale et malgré les déclarations
que j'avais lu dans la presse selon
lesquelles le dernier mot serait donnée
à l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
a pris acte de la volonté du sénat et
renoncer aux dispositifs proposés
c'est une victoire pour le sénat et
c'est une victoire pour notre famille
politique comme je l'avais indiqué
l'introduction de ce commissaire du
gouvernement au détour d'un amendement
sur un texte de transposition de
directive renforçant les pouvoirs du
régulateur nous paraissait pour le moins
inapproprié
il y avait un problème au regard du
droit européen qui avait été soulignée
par un certain nombre de responsables de
la commission européenne il y avait
également un risque évident de conflit
d'intérêts l'état étant actionnaire
majoritaire de la poste et actionnaire
principal de france télécom et au delà
nous sentions bien sur tous les bancs de
cette assemblée une volonté de reprise
en main d'une autorité administrative
indépendante
j'avais également souligné le caractère
paradoxal de cette attitude qui consiste
à vouloir contrôler davantage d autorité
administrative indépendante tout en
continuant ancrée et je ne savais pas en
disant cela il y à peine quatre semaines
que le gouvernement annoncerait si vite
sa volonté de créer encore une haute
autorité administrative indépendante
cette fois pour prévenir les conflits
d'intérêts alors s'en remettre en cause
la nécessité d'agir rapidement
sur cette question puisque je les ai moi
même souligner ici même à cette tribune
il y à moins d'une semaine lors des
débats sur le paquet électoral
il me semble que nous aurions beaucoup à
gagner à ne pas systématiquement céder à
la tentation des autorités
administratives indépendantes sur un
autre sujet je ne peux en revanche que
regretter la suppression par la
commission mixte paritaire de
l'amendement que j'avais déposé avec les
membres du groupe de l'union centriste
sur la couverture du territoire en
téléphonie mobile
cet amendement prévoyait qu'une comines
qu'une commune ne puisse être considérée
comme couverte que lorsqu'elle est
réellement couverte et non pas comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
dès lors qu'un seul point de la commune
est couvert voté une première fois en
décembre dernier lors de l'examen de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
mars 1 avec l'as où tu ne soutiens de la
commission de l'économie de ce
rapporteur pierre hérisson
cet amendement avait à nouveau
bénéficier d'un large soutien sur
l'ensemble des bancs du sénat
il n'a pas recueilli l'assentiment de la
commission mixte paritaire et je le
regrette car cette question préoccupe au
plus haut point les territoires ruraux
dont nous sommes les représentants comme
les territoires sont d'ailleurs
préoccupé par l'ensemble des questions
relatives à l'aménagement numérique du
territoire
fort heureusement le sénat et tout
particulièrement la commission de
l'économie ne désarment pas et ne
renonce pas sur cette importante
question puisque ce matin même nous
avons examiné le rapport de notre
collègue sido sur la couverture du
territoire en téléphonie mobile rapport
qui nous confirme que des progrès sont
encore à faire pour améliorer la
couverture en 2g et en 3g
toujours dans le cadre des efforts
déployés par notre commission
nous travaillons actuellement à la
rédaction d'un rapport sur la couverture
numérique du territoire c'est-à-dire la
téléphonie mobile le haut et le très
haut débit fixe et mobile
il débouchera avant l'été sur une
proposition de loi qui sera cosigné par
notre collègue le roi
car il ne suffit pas de dresser des
constats il faut aussi proposer des
solutions adaptées et de ce point de vue
là madame le ministre
les annonces du gouvernement
fusse-t-elle ambitieuse ne satisfont
plus celles et ceux de nos concitoyens
qui sont encore aujourd'hui privés d'un
véritable accès haut débit
le vote par deux fois de cet amendement
par le sénat aura au moins permis de
montrer aux opérateurs à quel point
notre exaspération est grande sur ce
sujet je terminerai mon intervention en
vous disant à nouveau mon regret que le
gouvernement est touchée pour que nous
ne débattrons pas au fond des questions
qui préoccupent nos concitoyens en
matière de numérique
nous aurions pu et nous aurions dû à
l'occasion de la transposition de ces
directives examiner la question du
service universel à l'internet haut
débit comme cela est désormais possible
nous aurions pu et nous aurions dû
également examiné la question de la
séparation fonctionnelle nous ne l'avons
pas fait le débat sur les questions de
fond a été délibérément à la fois
par le choix d'une transposition par
voie d'ordonnancé
mais aussi par l'attitude du
gouvernement je suis au regret de le
dire qui n'a répondu à aucune des
questions que nous avons posées au cours
des débats
j'avais interrogé le ministre pour
savoir comment le gouvernement compte et
permettre à nos concitoyens d'accéder
aux véritables haut débit pour tous
promis récemment encore par le premier
ministre je l'avais interrogé pour lui
demander de confirmer que l'attribution
des fréquences issues du dividende
numérique se ferait bien conformément à
la loi
en privilégiant l'aménagement du
territoire et non pas des critères de
rentabilité
je n'ai obtenu aucune réponse j'observe
d'ailleurs qu'il y a une certaine
constance de la part du gouvernement
puisque lorsque le ministre a été
auditionné par la commission de
l'économie le 16 février
je lui ai posé un certain nombre de
questions auxquelles je n'ai obtenu
aucune réponse
je me réjouis que le gouvernement ait
progressé récemment sur la dimension
sociale de la fracture numérique en
signant avant-hier une convention avec
les opérateurs afin de proposer d'ici à
six mois un tarif social mobile
labellisé par l'état
nous attendons qu'ils agissent également
enfin en ce qui concerne la dimension
territoriale de la fracture numérique et
qu'il ne se contente pas d fred annonce
malgré ces réserves le texte issu des
travaux de la commission mixte paritaire
nous apportons la satisfaction de voir
respecter une position forte de notre
assemblée de notre groupe et les délais
de transposition étant ce qu'ils sont
nous voterons ce texte avec peu
d'enthousiasmé voulait comprimé nous de
votre sénateur la discussion générale
est close
je ne suis saisi d'aucun amendement je
vais donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire
oui madame hermange et mes chers
collègues je veux dire que je ne voterai
pas ce texte conformément à ce que
j'avais exprimé en commission des
affaires sociales il verrière m'excuser
de ne pas devoir était présente en
séance mais la vérité je me suis trompé
de semaine dans rue du vent pour trois
raisons d'abord les raisons évoquées par
notre collègue barbier sur
l'assouplissement des règles en matière
de certificats des dispositifs médicaux
si nous avons aujourd'hui vous le savez
madame ministre sur notre sol
un certain nombre d'inquiétudes en
matière de médicaments
nous en avons aussi en matière de
dispositifs médicaux où nous sommes
moins contraignants et les dispositions
qui sont prévus dans cette directive ne
permettent pas vont permettre un
assouplissement qui qui peut être
inquiétant la deuxième raison c'est
qu'alors que nous allons examiner dans
quinze jours
un texte sur la bioéthique et avec tout
un chapitre sur la recherche sur les
cellules souches et sur les seuls
souches embryonnaires
le texte tel qu'il nous est proposé ici
avec la transposition de cette directive
le précède
puisque il modifie d'une part l'article
l 11 25,1 en matière de médicaments de
thérapie innovante
ainsi que l'article 51 21 1
concernant les produits issus de
l'ingénierie tissulaire ou des
médicaments combinés de thérapies
innovantes donc le texte que nous allons
voter précède le débat et l'article
concernant la problématique sur la
recherche sur les cellules souches et la
troisième raison madame la ministre
c'est que nous avions une cmp qui était
prévu ce matin pour discuter du texte
sur la recherche sur les personnes
or cette cmp a été annulée au motif
qu'il y aurait une directive européenne
en la matière cette directive nous ne la
connaissons pas d'un côté
j'observe qu'il faut se presser dans le
cadre du travail législatif pour
transposer cette directive et de l'autre
nous n'avons pas encore de directive et
on nous demande de surseoir à notre
travail désiste hâtives donc ce n'est
pas dans les habitudes
mais pour ces trois raisons je ne
pourrai pas voter ce texte
merci la parole est à madame brigitte
nous merci madame la présidente je
m'exprime au nom du groupe ump
monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame la ministre et mes
chers collègues nous sommes parvenus au
terme de l'examen du projet de loi
portant diverses dispositions
d'adaptation au droit communautaire en
matière de santé de travail et de
communications électroniques
il s'agit de transposer des directives
soit directement soit en habilitant le
gouvernement à le faire par voie
d'ordonnancé en particulier s'agissant
du paquet télécom je tiens tout d'abord
à saluer la qualité du travail des
rapporteurs
madame colette quilichini catherine
c'est morin desailly ainsi que monsieur
bruno retailleau ce processus de
transposition subit fréquemment des
retards qu'ils génèrent
les difficultés de plusieurs ordres
d'une part des difficultés d'ordre
financier
en effet le montant des amendes et
désastres un peut atteindre des dizaines
de millions d'euros dans un contexte de
budget contraint nous devons nous
attacher à minimiser ces pénalités
financières
d'autre part au-delà de l'impact de ces
amendes sur nos finances publiques
si la crédibilité de notre pays qui est
en jeu
si nous voulons rester un acteur majeur
de la scène européenne nous devons mener
à bien l'harmonisation de la
réglementation communautaire
le groupe ump dans sa main grande
majorité approuve les mesures initiées
par notre assemblée
parmi ces avancées je citerai la
création d'un mécanisme de solidarité
financière entre petites communes
destinées à permettre un partage des
charges liées à la tenue de l'état civil
au profit de la commune qui accueille un
hôpital intercommunal comportant une
maternité
l'encadrement plus rigoureux de la
fabrication des médicaments de thérapie
innovante et la formation des élèves à
l'utilisation de l'informatique et des
outils interactifs
enfin le volet télécommunications a été
renforcée avec des dispositions touchant
notamment au régime des noms de domaine
et à l'intersection à l'interconnexion
des réseaux
nous nous félicitons à cet égard de
l'affirmation du principe de neutralité
des réseaux
le groupe ump votera donc ce texte je
vous remercie
merci madame la sénatrice la parole est
avec michel teston merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre chères et
chers collègues ont eu l'occasion il ya
quelques minutes d'expliquer
l'appréciation portée par le groupe
socialiste sur ce projet de loi je me
limiterai à quelques brèves remarques
sur la méthode et sur le fond sur la
méthode l'urgence ne justifie
absolument pas la méthode de
transposition qui a été retenue c'est à
dire la loi d'habilitation janvier au
fond en distinguant même si
l'appréciation globalement est la même
la partie relative à la santé au travail
la partie relative aux
télécommunications
le contenu des dispositions relatives à
la santé au travail ne conviennent pas
notre groupe
et s'agissant du paquet télécom le
recours aux ordonnances ne permet pas
d'aborder des points essentiels comme le
service universel ou l'attribution de
francs de fréquences rendues disponibles
par le dividende numérique
nous regrettons en outre gelé déjà dit
lors de la discussion générale que la
commission mixte paritaire soit revenu
sur l'amendement adopté en première
lecture pour améliorer la couverture des
communes rurales par la téléphonie
mobile pour ses diverses raisons le
groupe socialiste votera contre ce
projet de loi c'est président fischer
oui je crois que le groupe crc spg et
fondamentalement contre ce projet de loi
on a invoqué un certain nombre ont
d'autres raisons et à travers les
interventions de nos différents
collègues
on voit bien que le doute est partagé à
l'intérieur de chaque groupe et
notamment pour notre part sur les
questions de santé de travail
on voit bien que nous sommes à travers
ce texte en train de franchir sans le
dire sans associer véritablement et bien
la population les françaises et les
français mais les associations les
organisations syndicales
eh bien nous sommes en train de franchir
des frontières qui remettront en cause
fondamentalement ce qu'ils étaient
notre système normatif jusqu'à présent
et je faisais allusion dans mon
intervention à la présence nombreux deux
présidents de conseils généraux dans
notre assemblée entre 30 et 35
avec tous les problèmes liées notamment
au secteur du médico et médico social
avec bien sûr les problèmes d pad on
sait que nous aurons l'occasion dans
l'année qui vient de discuter d'un texte
de loi importants la dépendance mais qui
semble madame la ministre
être reportée aux calendes grecques
puisque nous n'aurons certainement et
vraisemblablement que certaines
dispositions dans le prochain budget de
la sécurité sociale alors que nous
aurions voulu en discuter véritablement
sur le fond eh bien on voit qu'il y a à
travers ce texte toute une série de
barrières qui sont franchies de
nouvelles frontières qui vont s'imposer
à nous et je crois que nous découvrirons
au fur et à mesure de la mise en place
de cela
qu' il y a eu de profonds changements
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien et
c'est pour cela que je partageais le
point de vue de colette giudicelli qui a
dit eh bien nous serons amenés à faire
le point de la mise en oeuvre de ce
texte et plus particulièrement
moi je pense au secteur de la santé du
travail où il y à de profonds de
changement alors bien sûr dans notre
jargon du groupe communiste ont dit bah
on est en train de jeter par dessus bord
tout ce qui était les normes que l'on a
mis en place depuis la libération
mais je crois que aujourd'hui eh bien il
faut être très attentif à tout cela et
c'est pour cela que l'on ne peut que
conforter notre opposition à de tels
textes qui passe à l'insu du plus grand
nombre qui sont qui vont s'imposer
réglementairement et je crois que dans
cette période
mais bien sûr avec la création du
conseiller territorial et la disparition
des conseils généraux j'espère bien que
changera les choses bien avant pour que
l'on puisse revenir sur des problèmes de
fond dans une période où la crise
économique et sociale est très important
et des chômeurs et les précaires qui
manifestaient tout à l'heure près de
notre palais du luxembourg et bien été
là pour nous le rappeler
et je voudrais madame la présidente
faire un rappel au règlement pour
terminer car il y avait une
manifestation qui avait été autorisé et
je trouve anormal
alors que cette manifestation est bien
étaient peu nombreuses qu'on est
interdit d'accès du jardin du luxembourg
pour manger le petit casse-croûte qu'ils
avaient prévu alors qu'il ne comptait
absolument pas manifestée dans le jardin
du luxembourg
on leur a interdit l'accès et c'était
des citoyens
des français qui se trouvent dans des
situations terribles et bien cela croyez
moi je l' ai vécu ma douloureusement
heureusement que je n'étais pas là parce
que j'interpelle officiellement au nom
de mes collègues et dany david bien
entendu bon je trouve que l'on pouvait
au moins permettre l'accès au banc pour
qu'ils puissent manger leur casse-croûte
quoi on marche sur la tête
merci je vous donne acte de ce rappel au
règlement monsieur le président je vais
donc mettre aux voix l'ensemble du texte
élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire qui votent pour qu'ils votent
contre abstentions le sénat a adopté
définitivement le projet de loi
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance à
suivre sur notre antenne preuve par
trois avec ce soir comme invité rama
yade merci de votre fidélité bonne fin
de journée à tous